老鱼從學生時代就已經接觸起貨
到今天已經超過了15年
他曾經在幾個月內獲利200萬元
也曾經在一天之內賠掉近百萬
本來不該跌破的位置
跌破了
結果卻被一個神祕的力量買回來
變成跌不破
這個時候我就會想
神祕力量到底是誰
現在的他不做基本面
不看K線
只用一招必勝SOP
就能夠穩穩獲利
究竟他是怎麼做到的
我們一起來看看嗎
上華最近股市這樣跌了一塌糊塗
你有沒有進場
上次那個觀眾啊
看了有一集還說
上華是不是套很多
他在表情都沒有在笑
是喔 你看我今天
今天也有笑啦
長言歡笑
幹嘛要這樣子
對啊
但是今天我們要介紹另外一個
其實我們在相關經濟學
講了好幾次期貨
無論是國內的
還是海外的這樣子
可是我覺得期貨呢
真的是富貴險中求人
至少在我的概念裡面
我覺得我都不敢去碰他了
可是今天來到現場的少年古神
老魚這樣子
看你很年輕耶
但是你叫老魚
你在機農市場這樣操作很久了嗎
大概到現在15 16年了吧
15 16年
這樣也不算太久啊
像很多人就是學生時代開始輸
所以你是20多歲才開始
20大概4 24 25歲
大學畢業以後
為什麼一開始會接觸到期貨呢
很簡單啊
身邊的朋友在賺錢
那是我沒有開戶
他在賺錢
然後跟我說這個禮拜我又賺2萬
下禮拜又跟我說我又賺2萬
你心不會癢癢的人
會啊
那你自己那時候每個月獲利到多少
那算在做什麼
我那時候剛開始是做台灣的
我做選擇權
台灣的選擇權
然後就是把我的資金壓進去
例如說我壓2萬
然後做多
放一天 变4万 卖掉
然后再丢进去 4万买进去
然后再隔一天 变8万 卖掉
就这样子 我也不知道我在干嘛
我真的不知道我在干什么
这可能是当时行情好
所以站在风口连猪都会飞的那种概念
我当时就是那只猪
但是我不知道
你真的以为自己是古神这样对不对
当时券商的营业员还邀请我
回去那边办演讲说
余先生你好厉害
然后他讲完这个的隔天
我就拜拜了
就2008年的金融海啸吗
我就赔钱了
就赔钱了
结果你最多的时候赚到多少
碰到金融海啸的时候赔多少
第一波是三个月
我大概把10万11万的钱
变成大概200
那真的就是股神啊
对啊
所以他们就想要请我回去演讲
然后股灾的第一天我就赔30万
然后股灾第二天又赔30
那剩下的钱在接下来一个月内
很快的就
就吐出去了
就不只吐出去還倒賠
對還倒賠
那時候到底是犯了什麼錯誤
還是你其實真的前面都只是幸運
一開始是幸運
但是後來我跑去想說我賠錢了
我就跑去書局買一大堆書回來看
各種指標我要研究的
我全部都去學
後來我一路賠錢的最大的關鍵是
我學太多
學太多
招式太多但不會使用
因為我
例如說這個地方是KD指標
可能低檔翻揚黃金較差
但是均线可能又要在上面
我到底要相信这个还是这个
嗯哼
我不知道
你有综合判断的能力
对不对
或是说我综合判断太多
因为我判断了两个
那这两个在打架
我就加入第三个指标
就是你自己觉得哪个
然后第三个指标
但是好像又有点不确定
那我加入一些基本面
基本面看一下
我又再加入均线
加入哇一直加
所以加到最后我综合判断
判断到我也不知道该怎么办
所以以至于
我的招式没有固定下来
我一直在寻找所谓的圣杯
是
所以就很像那种练武的人
然后太贪心
到最后整个经脉错乱
是
但听到你一次是一个晚上赔掉了100万喔
呃
实际金额是33000的美金
哦
那是已经做海外的了
那时候我已经在做海外了
就是我现在常做的小大师大哥
那为什么
那到底发生了什么事情
因为那个晚上
我的整个星期的情绪不对
所以
我被市場打掉以後
例如說我按下去賠錢
對
我就不爽
Double我的部位
兩倍按下去同一個方向
結果又賠錢
但是把我打掉以後立刻又彈上去
所以你的心情就是
就不爽了你知道嗎
對
然後你就會想要
要拚
2口不行
4口
8口
停損停損
可惡每次停損都把我打掉
好這次不停損
不停損這次我的部位
我記得是4口
然後一路抱下來
所以我是先賠500美金我不跑
賠800 賠1000 賠5000
不管再拗
賠8000 賠10000 再拗
一不小心等我回過神來
33000就
33000美金就沒了
就100多萬台幣
就一個晚上
實際上大概才兩個小時以內的事情
然後那兩個小時
我像殺紅的眼影一樣
就是一直按一直按
那我的交易紀錄是好多頁的交易紀錄
不過還好嘛
你繳了學費以後也的確有所得
因為你現在呢
也經過了這麼長時間練習
找到了一套
就是你交易期貨的必勝SOP
所以一定要趕快教我們大家
什麼是你的必勝SOP
我要澄清一下
我沒有必勝
勝率提高
因為如果必勝的話
我今天就不用來了
對啊
很誠實
對嘛
因為在講必勝的時候
現在網友就刷一排
那今天來這邊幹什麼
真的
對啊
那不然對上單啊
真的沒有必勝
我反而認為交易本質上是賭場
那我能做的是透過適當的觀察
觀察出現在的賠率
現在的機率對我比較有利
是
那我在這個邊界區域下單
可是你知道我看這張圖
我不知道SOP在哪裡
那你的SOP是什麼
我的SOP其實有幾個
一個很重要的關鍵叫做三問
三問
第一個問是
問天問第一問自己
問大滴
搞不好可以賣
那我講唱歌
三問是
第一個位置對不對
好
第二慣性對不對
第三圖對不對
圖對不對
所以我會先問自己說
現在的相對位置是高還是低
如果前一次的價格是從50漲到100那100就是不對的位置50就是對的位置所以我就會規劃說我在50的這個地方
等它從上面疊下來
疊破50
再漲回來
又在50這邊鬼混
就是這個圖
就是這張圖
這個時候我就可以在50邊界
好像
50下不去
49 50 49 50 下不去
那我就買 買在50
的附近
差不多
那我的防守剛剛到49下不去
那我的防守就是48 47
就是剛剛下不去的那個價格
再往下一些些
不用很多
因為我想要越短的停損越好
是 這樣子
所以這個是以做多的方向去思考的
對不對
如果是做空
這張圖只是把它倒過來
倒過來看
因為這是做多的思考的方式
對不對
所以能幫我們舉例一下嗎
舉個例子是像你們現在看到這張圖
我說我的腦袋永遠都是在底下的水平面這邊
我就規劃好一個是這是我要吃的位置
那你看看這張圖
其實我有把一個圖形放上去
注意我接下來講這句話很重要
本來不該跌破的位置
跌破了
結果卻被一個神秘的力量買回來
變成跌不破
那這個時候我就會想
神秘力量到底是誰
其實不重要
重點是他買了
那能夠在市場上面
能夠撼動指數的
絕對不會是小咖
絕對不會是三兩銀這樣子
真的
那是算百億的這樣
那我不知道他發生什麼事
我也不知道他根據什麼因素
也不必要知道對不對
不需要知道
那我看到的是他做了
他的身體很誠實
他做了一件事
本來跌破的地方
又被這個人買回來
然後在這個價格附近鬼混
就是這條紅線
就在這裡對不對
就是在這裡
那個地方在那邊鬼混
所以我就會在那邊
我就跟著吃一些木味
然後我也不知道
未來會不會長
會不會跌
可是老魚
因為這張線圖
已經是我們長期看
已經拉出來了
有點事後諸葛
對
我在那個當下
我可能在這附近的時候
我怎麼知道
它是不是就是已經是
如果說到這邊的時候
我們哪知道就知道
對吧 到底該怎麼知道對不對
那我用一張圖來給大家
這是我真實的交易
到後面會有我真實的下單
那這張圖是我一路跟著行情過來
我觀察到什麼東西
那盤中我如何思考
第一個是行情從上面一路掉下來
掉到這個地方
下來一個價格下不去
它彈起來就像皮球一樣
我發現有兩個點
這個是慣性對不對
這兩個點在差不多的位置都停住
那我是不是有兩個點
我可以畫出一條水平線
是
這時候我的位置的第一優先
我就先跑出來
這個位置可能是對的
這是我當時看到
我還沒有下任何的部位
我在期待它出現我剛剛的第一張圖
出現這個東西
就是像超跌一样的
对 那我的心中其实就已经想说
这个边界我需要它跌破
它没有跌破以前我不会出手
所以这时候它就立为观察了
是 我已经知道这个边界差不多了
好 观察 观察 跌破后的长相
如果跌破后都站不回来
那我也不会下单
但是如果跌破后又站回来
那我心中就会有一个
好像可以找机会的
那第二步
它行情在這個邊界
它就走了一段時間
到了遮住的最末端這邊
它跌破了有一個下引線
那對市場來講
下引線的定義是
這個邊界跌下去
被一個神秘力量很快速的
拉回來
就會出現這個叫做引線
那它引線掌的位置
是不是在這個邊界區域
這個框框的外面
所以下引線朝外
那我就叫它說尖尖的
尖尖的朝下
那我就规划说
这个区域如果行情又涨破
又掉回来
所以这时候其实
我们原来刚刚判断的那个图形
已经完成一半
但是我需要另外一半
如果没有另外一半
我就是在旁边等着它
你要再烟
我就不理它
我就放着就好了
那我就继续等
结果行情突然间往上喷
哇 跌破底后往上喷
這一噴我心中就會知道說
剛剛在規劃的底下的邊界
哎呦這邊界不錯
我等它回來
我不會追
那為什麼我不追
你看像現在我這裡
這個行情噴上來到最上面這個位置
我一往左邊對過去
往這個市場的左邊對過去
這是剛剛的地板
來到這邊我正好是從一樓往上撞
撞二樓的天花的地板
對
我不要當那個人
我不想要當那個去撞牆的人
是
那所以我就一樣
把我原來的區域
你們要只是在這裡帶你
對 你就把天花板跟地板
都全部看出來了
你的空間格局就是這樣
我的空間格局在這裡
這個格局不是我自己想的
是市場定義給我的
那我就畫好
上面的線在這邊
下面的線在這邊
那我在下面
我要做多嘛
那我就在下面等你
哦
那
後面
這個地方我有下一個單子
這裡你們有看到
黃色箭頭出我有下一個單子
這個單子就是
因為我看到我所熟悉的圖形
那我就在這個邊界區域
我在這裡下單
那這裡我出手
那大家可以看得到的是
我出手以後被
美幾根以後面的這個行情給下殺
那這個意思是我守我的成本
所以代表我這一次的賭博
不賺不賠
平手了
出場 至少還好 我沒有真的虧錢
但是也沒有真的賭成功
市場又繼續的震盪
往上跑 又再度回來這個地方
再度回來這個地方 我又做測試
這次測試 我在這個邊界測試了兩次
第一次測試 我吃了兩個部位 失敗
你有看到 就是這個 是失敗的部位
我吃在這邊 然後吃完沒多久
蹦蹦 就打下去
後面這個
這兩個的判斷對我來講是切開來的我的心中已經沒有剛剛的單子我的心中是從位置對不對對啊 大邊界對慣性呢 慣性其實好像也差不多沒有跌破圖咧 圖是不是
是不是我要的圖
要的大邊界的圖的邊界
是 那如果這些都是
我今天又還有子彈可以打
好 那我就打
然後打了 運氣還不錯
我在這邊先出了一個部位
然後還留一個部位繼續丟著
所以我底下的觀察的邊界就是
我在看的就是這幾個東西
前面這兩個箭頭
然後包含我最旁邊這個箭頭
我在看的就是剛剛下不去的點
中間下去的卻被拉回來
然後又下不去
那我的前面有一個尖尖的往下
就是這個尖尖的跌破最下面的下面拉回來
那我就在這個邊界關門放垢
我最喜歡的就是當那個
我想要讓最喜歡
收官的人
就是這個邊界
這個邊界我要認賠也很輕鬆很簡單
很快就可以認賠
可是我覺得這種做短
因為是5分K嘛
所以它其實在短線上面
它的波動是非常非常大的
而且你這樣彈上去之後
那你的停力怎麼算呢
通常我的停力
如果是簡單來講用金額來算
如果我承受100美金的風險
那我的停利通常會抓500到1000美金
就是這一次的交易
五倍或十倍
大約 那這個是初步的
那如果我運氣不錯
或是說我有兩個部位
我第二個部位我就會抓更遠一點
說不定抓到1500或是2000美金一口
這樣子的部位去做
不過老虞其實你剛剛教我們的這套SOP
你把它稱之為破底翻嘛
那如果破底翻一旦不小心失敗了
那你的停損點大概會怎麼設
就是最近下不去的價格
例如說我吃在這裡
最近下不去的邊界
就是這兩個下影線的最末端
那我就是防守
最近下不去的價格以外
一些些
就這樣而已
那這個金額
從我在做期貨來講
金額大概在100美金
100到120塊美金左右
就我一次出手
一口單的話就給這樣子
所以我不會用很大的停損
去承受它的大幅度的波動
如果說我們學會了
大致上了解這樣子的操作模式的話
近期你有比較關注的期貨指數嗎
近期 因為我從看很多
到現在一直刪刪刪
我變成看很少
看很少反而我的心情
我的整個時間變得很開心 很專注
我可以撥給我的站跟時間
所以我最常看的就是
美國的科技股的期貨
就是納斯達克
那我每天做來做去
都是在做這個CME的納斯達克企業
是
這樣
那
我每天在做的這個
它到底是蘋果的股票發生什麼事
或是Amazon發生什麼事
坦白講我不知道
不過其實像你自己在說
你在做這個美股的納斯達克
那像現在美股進入一個
多空交戰的一個狀態
你怎麼看未來後世的發展
還有在操作的策略上面
會有一些不一樣的改變嗎
坦白講美股好的低點布局的時間點
坦白講已經過了
已經過了
對 現在的時間有點卡在
已經漲了一段上來
那現在你就要再等下一次它再回落
回落到前一個跌不下去的地方
如果哲星哥
你現在有把美股的日線打開來
你會發現今天現在日線的位置
是前一次日線的高點
所以代表前一次买在這邊的人
現在都會尋求解套
那我不想跳進去幫他解套
我想等到他們再被殺一次
然後下不去了
好 那才換我
是 所以在這種多空交戰的情況之下
還有美國的升息
升息我覺得到年底好像在繼續嘛 對不對
所以在期貨操作上面的話
你竟然還是偏向保守對不對
我就完全看圖做了
看圖做這樣
就是圖有沒有出現我要的東西
我就照著做
是 不談感情
也不認識那個人這樣子
其實不談感情反而比較好
是齁
我跟他談戀愛的結果都很不好
就是關起燈來的
什麼東西
不過其實老虞你自己一直以來是
股市跟期貨都有做
那現在很多人會覺得說
如果股市在不好的狀態之下
可以使用期貨來避險
那怎麼來使用呢
避險我跟各位講的就是
避在對的時間點很重要
什麼叫對的時間點
你們有沒有聽過要避險的人越避越險
他明明要避險
到在這邊底下做一些空單避險
結果行情漲上去
所以做多的賠錢空單也被尬上來了
挖
所以避險的想法
你必須要是這樣子
是假設你是已經是
好幾個月以前
甚至是去年買的多頭部位
台積電買在500塊
然後漲到600多
我說之前買在500塊的
漲到600多了
你害怕損失這一段的價差
但是你又不想要短線賣掉你手上的股票
在上面去做一些空頭的避險
這個才比較合理
但是如果你是已經你買在600多
都已經跌到500了
跌到480你才要避險
這是完全不合理的事情
你已經從這邊賠到這裡了
那最有可能的反而會是越幣越險
所以買的位置其實
買的位置很重要
所以如果你是今天買
那你為了害怕你手上的部位產生虧損
那因為你是現在就買買
害怕未來產生虧損
那這時候避險合理
不能去避很舊以前的那些
買套在上面的那已經來不及了
對 因為其實有很多的觀眾就不太了解
到底股票跟期貨的差別在哪裡
那期貨的優勢到底有哪些
期貨的好處是
它可以用比較少的錢
做到同樣的股票
就開槓桿就對了
開槓桿的意思
但要挑對時間點
對 要挑對時間點
而且我想要講的是
期貨給你這麼大的槓桿
但是你不需要用這麼多的槓桿去做
它槓桿給你20倍
你自己多放一倍的錢
你降到10倍
不要用剛剛好的錢
就去做剛剛好的事那個很容易會賠錢但是它的好處就是如果你同樣要做交易同一筆錢 槓桿稍微放大一些你在遵守風控的情形下
因為期貨帶槓桿
獲利的出蓄的速度
會大於你純粹沒有帶槓桿的股票
但是還是不要開太高
不要 不要 真的不建議
還有老魚你有提到
當天買賣不用怕融資券的問題
這點有什麼特別要注意的呢
期貨的好處是
像我們做股票
如果你要融資或是你要放空
它有資券的問題
有時候可能是沒有券等等
那在期貨裡面好處就是
它多空其實你隨時要做
它都很OK
不見得一定手上要有券
有什麼才能夠做
所以它的靈活性我覺得還不錯
那既然如此的話
因為大家我們每天
我打開APP裡面看到的都是台紙期
可是我們剛剛一開始聊的時候
老雲你跟我說
你是做的是海外期貨
為什麼
為什麼做海外企業
因為第一個是他的交易時間
其實比台灣的太子企長蠻多的
是喔
他從他一天有23個小時都有開盤
23個小時
他只休息一個小時
所以也就是說
從我們台灣時間早上6點鐘開始
他就開盤了
是
然後一路做到凌晨5點
凌晨5點
對
所以這段時間
如果你是真的有
例如說有一些事件發生
你需要做避險
台湾已经收盘了 怎么办
那边可以做
对 而且一般上班族下班
还可以继续做
在早上起来做早超的时候
就可以开始做了
其实早超的时候
我蛮常在早上吃到一段早餐的行情
甚至是在台股都还没开盘以前
大概7点的附近就有一些
一波行情可以做
蛮常见的
真的早起的鸟有虫吃
所以来教育时间长
那第二个其实我觉得很好奇
是它没有涨跌幅的限制
其實他在盤中還是有
是美國現貨開盤後
他的限制才會一步一步的整個打開
所以在電子盤時間
就是美國的我們台灣白天的時間
他的漲碟幅還是有被限制住
但是一旦到了晚上
他們電子盤一開
他漲碟幅就開始整個打開了
也就是說如果我要做到一波
同樣的一波行情
在這邊可能單位時間裡面
能夠產生的利潤或許會多一些
是
不過其實像剛剛老雲你這麼說啦
當然對我們來講
我們覺得時間上更彈性啊
然後同時整跌幅的限制
也不會這麼的縮緊嘛
那如果有些小資族想要開始來
嘗試看看的話
有沒有一些比較簡單
輕便的做法可以建議大家
如果是小資族
其實我會建議是
用很小的資金先測試
不要一開始就當少年股神
真的真的
我體會過那種感覺是很不好的
那像CME他們有
像我在做的是正常的小納
就是小型納斯達克起貨
CME有微型的
那微型的是1.1的規格
那1.1的規格就是你不需要拿到
原始這麼大的保證據
拿壓碎錢就可以出來玩
差不多是這種感覺
幾百塊 樣幾千塊就可以
但是壓碎錢出來玩
你可能再多放個
例如說兩三倍的壓碎錢
然後拿來玩
一倍压碎钱的事情
是这样子
但是它的好处就是
例如说我现在下一口
微型的小NAS
大概会等于25000美金的合约规格
但是你却不需要拿出25000美金出来
是这样子
微型小NAS达克
它我就有个好处
它流动性很高
所以你不用怕买不到
或是卖不出息的这个风险
有一些股票没有什么流动性
你如果是套在那边
你想卖但是卖不掉
哇这很可怜
其實大部分的老師來到下班經營學
我覺得最重要的還是勸勢的部分
真的
勸勢的部分裡面大家就講的就是風險管理
怎麼樣去健全我們這種風險管理
不要管理市場 管理自己
管理自己嘛
因為大部分的人管理風險
都是在管理市場的風險
是
NO 自己才是最大的風險
他們就監控市場的風險
這是錯的
但是市場風險就是你該要有的SOP
基本上你都要有
但是一旦自己的心亂掉
我跟我老婆一吵架
禁書房一按就是賠10萬
所以監控自己的
反而會比監控市場
我覺得來的更重要
所以它上面有寫到交易的一致性
也就是說這個紀律很重要是不是
一致性除了紀律以外
也有固定的出手動作
固定的出手
就像剛才那個SOB
圖形嗎
就像如果你有看打棒球的話
棒球球員他們的出手的時候
其實他們都要求
在揮棒的時候
身體不要開掉 腰不要開掉
維持一致的姿勢
但是打出去以後
會是拳臉打 安打 被截殺
沒有人知道
但是他就是盡可能維持他的動作
重點就是先打到球
對不對
所以分兩個動作
第一個先選球
我不要的球 我就不要
壞球不要
然後在好球帶裡頭
在這裡面的球我才要
好球來了
那這時候我就把我的思緒
拉回來到一致性
我要如何建立我的一致性
球來了 揮
那這個一致性的動作
跟在剛剛的過程中
其實已經有講過
就是這種一致性
是 而且這一致性裡面
就是剛才講的心態調整
剛才那一口已經被打掉了
沒關係 每一口重新開始這樣子
而且你有講到
挑異次數不用太多
真的這也是老魚的一致性
也跟打球很像啊
就兩好三揮
不能揮太多次
不用拼命揮爆這樣
我自己的經驗我分享一下
我自己一天出手次數
超過四五十次的
從來沒有賺錢過
那當我的出手次數在5次8次以內
通常那些都是輕輕鬆鬆
啊 探急
探急
是
小孩子的補習費有了
大概是這種感覺
但是如果我把小孩的補習費的心情放進來
我要賺小孩的補習費
我就會賠掉一台車子
哦
不要得失心
我只要想要賺尿布錢
賺補習費
我一想
啊是啊
是啊
對
所以你就要進入無我的狀態這樣
完全就以交易為恆星
是有點難
但是被電過幾次以後
你就會知道我還是無我一點好
是
我覺得今天這個很勸勢
可以來嘗試看看
今天謝謝老吟 謝謝
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目